han insistido en que estas sanciones
este paquete de sanciones que anunció
hoy el presidente yo bailes el paquete
de sanciones financiera más duro que
impuesto eeuu en su historia dice que va
dirigido precisamente aislar a rusia del
sistema financiero internacional a pesar
de que no haya incluido haber sancionado
haber cortado a rusia del sistema
financiero swift que era lo que pedía
específicamente el gobierno ucraniano
sin embargo pues menciona que estas
sanciones van destinadas a aislar a
rusia de tener más capacidad militar por
ejemplo de tener más capacidad
tecnológica de
tratar de bloquear la actividad
económica de 13 grandes empresas rusas
que juntas tienen activos por más de 1,5
billones de dólares también hace
referencia a pues el impacto que pueda
tener estas sanciones a nivel local así
lo mencionaba el asesor adjunto de
seguridad nacional hace unos minutos
desde acá desde la casa blanca decía
pues estas sanciones iban
específicamente diseñadas para no tener
mucho impacto en el público
estadounidense en el estadounidense
promedio de cara a la inflación de cara
al alza en los precios de combustible
que esto pueda tener mencionó
específicamente el asesor de seguridad
adjunto que estas acciones sí sin
embargo van a tener un gran efecto en la
economía estadounidense mencionó por
ejemplo que ya los mercados en rusia
habían bajado un 30% el gobierno tuvo
que intervenir para que el bajonazo no
hubiera si no no no no fuese tan duro
mencionó por ejemplo la inflación que se
ya se empieza a sentir también en rusia
y dijo que hay que darle a estas
sanciones más o menos un mes como lo
dijo el presidente yo bailén para tratar
de ahogar a precisamente la economía
rusa y no permitirles el desarrollo de
tecnología y de desarrollar sus
productos y sus servicios para ser más
competitivos en el mundo
y cristobal tú que estás en washington
cuéntanos cuál es el ambiente allá en
washington y en las afueras de la casa
blanca
a las afueras de la casa blanca como
también a las afueras de la embajada
rusa en washington hay manifestaciones a
lo lejos ustedes de pronto no alcanzan a
escucharlo pero se escuchan estos
tambores en este momento al frente de la
casa blanca alrededor de 200 personas
muchas de ellas ucranianas que están
pidiendo entre otras cosas una lista de
10 temas de 10 sanciones están además
compartiendo también números de cuenta
para donar para donaciones que puedan
hacer estadounidenses desde acá y el
gobierno ucraniano y al ejército de
ucrania entre luego a mencionar
solamente cinco cosas o bueno un par de
cosas que están pidiendo bajarla en la
calificación crediticia de rusia y entre
otras cosas por ejemplo obligar que se
compre el barril de petróleo ruso a un
precio de 10 dólares por barril entre
otras sanciones que pide acá la gente
afuera de la casa blanca
y cristóbal muy ver muy brevemente ha
confirmado eeuu algo más sobre las zonas
tomadas por rusia en ucrania
eeuu y también las autoridades
ucranianas por ejemplo el tema de
chernóbil fue confirmado esta tarde por
autoridades ucranianas que ya estaba
pues en el control de los rusos un
aeropuerto muy cercano a quien también
estaba en disputa hace apenas unos unas
unas horas y que se decía que si rusia
tomaba control de este aeropuerto tenía
pues un acceso bastante
abierto a la capital ucraniana se le
cuestionó a la jefe de prensa acá en la
casa blanca que cuáles serían las
medidas de eeuu en caso de que en las
próximas horas y en la capital fuera
tomada por parte de los rusos y pues no
hay una respuesta concreta frente a esto